the teams that can win in all three
zones are the ones that find themselves
at the top of the standings and it's the
little battles throughout each game that
help keep win streaks alive great teams
know that games can be won and lost in
front of the net with all new net
battles in NHL 17 we're giving you the
defensive tools you need to control the
crucial real estate in front with you're
clearing the lane for your goalies line
of sight or tying up your opponent's
dick to take away a pass it's all about
timing and positioning to own your rice
effectively in the crease all new motion
capture has helped us replicate the
technical movements of modern-day NHL
goaltenders depending on position shot
angle and the scoring situation boys can
now use their bodies to stay big and
block versus relying on reactionary
saves to take our goalies a step further
we've added more than forty authentics
dances to bring out the true personality
of the league's best tenders once you've
done your job defensively improve
passing it's smoother puck pickups allow
for cleaner zone exits and more speed on
the breakout so when you prefer to carry
it in or play dump and chase in NHL 17
you'll have options on the break in your
speed is a weapon but make sure to keep
your head up as improved hit targeting
and better ability of knock players off
the pot make defending neutrals are more
effective than ever in the offensive
zone better pivots acceleration and
agility allow players to get into
dangerous positions more effectively
when you're in front of the net use your
body to spin off a check or push off
your defender at just the right month
for the tip in with improved defensive
tools and the most authentic goaltending
ever had solid team plant offense will
be essential to create quality scoring
chances just remember to celebrate with
style is over 30 all-new celebrations
let you rub that highlight reel in your
opponent space
you